from East LA to the Westside from
south-central to Pacoima there's Kobe
murals and you know it's a beautiful
thing
and this took us about three days to
paint I first got the news Sunday
morning pretty much as soon as it
happened I painted him a 2016 when he
retired I didn't think I would be
painting him again so quickly
definitely not under these circumstances
but being a group of friends who all
paint got together the next day and said
you know we should do something and like
you know the stars aligned and I got a
call from the owner here and he said hey
I would love to donate my wall and we
wanted to donate the artwork so you know
as a community we were able to come
together and create this you know
monument not just you know to sort of
express in our re our angst and our
anger at the situation but also to
provide sort of a community space for
for people who come together and gather
around Hopi and his legacy my biggest
surprise is just at the at the spectrum
the full spectrum of people that come
out and support the mural support Kobe
support the art it's it's it's just a
true testament to the to the man's you
know power and and the impact he had on
this city everybody from the honks to
the yellows to the social media posts
everybody's just ecstatic to have
something up and it's you know you would
think that with the saturation of Kobe
murals in the area that people would get
tired of seeing it but it doesn't seem
to be the case more and more and more
keep popping up every day and you know
it's it's a beautiful thing and again it
just shows the power of Kobe from East
LA to the Westside from south central to
Pacoima there's Kobe Merrill's and you
know it's a beautiful thing
he's only two years older than me so as
as you know as a kid he was when I
looked at he's my favorite everybody
knows he's my favorite I grew a fro like
him I used to try to you know try to
play like I'm on I wasn't but you know
he was just definitely on or off the
court he was my favorite person also I'm
like the true definition of a girl dad
like I have two daughters and then we
have one on the way another daughter so
I have three daughters so that the girl
dad hashtag was
when I saw it it was just it was awesome
I related to a definitely hundred
percent I just you know you see his
protege you know you could tell he was
gonna make her the one and you know it
said it was it still said I can't even
think about supply man Kobe gone and
think about his daughter and stuff and
everybody else affected in the tragedy
so just paying our respects while we're
out there we are we live in Vegas so I
just took the time off to spend time
with my family went to Universal Studios
long we came here to check out the
murals in cope in LA he meant a lot to
the city obviously uh everybody loved
him he was roasted nobody hated him
obviously there was a basketball right
here that nobody ever stole because I
feel like nobody will disrespect this
man so he was just love but prayers to
Vanessa in the family my president would
y'all
Kobe he meant a lot to me I mean just
like every Los Angeles native here the
five championships the great times with
family and friends and the community
watching him play was just amazing to
say the least and everybody wanted to be
Kobe on the court and for his loss it's
like you everyone literally lost a
little something but in memory ssin
these artists and I really love that
every artists out here in Los Angeles is
putting in the work in showing love and
support to Kobe GG and the whole family
she was the mamacita he was the mamba
and when we get from all of this is the
mama mentality I'm really just trying to
continue his legacy and if this mural
here can just do a little dust particle
and what he's already done in the world
that just puts a smile on my face and
warms my heart for sure
I'm from Japan but I'm a graduate
student in Oslo Norway and so I do art
and I'm currently doing my master's
program and before our I was really into
basketball and I'm like I was a I'm a
huge Lakers fan and also Kobe fan and
I'm here for the study trip for my
school but since she passed away last
month it was just like a good way to
just say thank you it's a it's more of
like a personal story but like last
semester when I started my school and
also I had like a hard time getting into
the environment and getting used to a
culture so like every day I would listen
to like Kobe's interviews and like at
schools like universities after he
retired and he would talk about like his
you know motivation and how to stay in
like a high level constantly so whenever
like I do artwork I would listen to Kobe
Bryant all the time and so this is just
my way to say thank you is to you know
do it in like an art form Kobe was a
huge part of my family growing up for me
not only was he an inspiration in his
basketball professional career but also
in his personal life and things he did
after basketball I feel very fortunate
to have been in that generation where we
heard his inspiration spiring words in
the comments he would make and things
that would motivate me personally so you
know this isn't only a tribute it's more
I think brings a community together
there's never any silver lining in a
situation like this but at the end of
the day hopefully all these murals that
are going up not just this one people
can see it and share a story to the next
generation and it could continue on
you